Hey there Shankar here. Today we wanted to bring you a bonus episode. It's a story we reported several years ago. It's about race and bias and the power of culture to affect our behavior. A quick note before we get started, this story begins with the police shooting of a man named Terrence Crutcher and this discussion of police violence against African Americans throughout the episode. On a September evening in 2016, Terence Croucher's SUV stopped in the middle of a road in Tulsa, Oklahoma. A woman saw him step out of the car. The doors of the car were open. The engine was still running. The woman called 911. Officer Betty Shelby was on her way to an unrelated incident when the call came in.
大家好，我是尚卡尔。今天我们想为您带来一期特别节目。这是一个我们多年前报道的故事。它关于种族、偏见以及文化影响我们行为的力量。在开始之前，有一个温馨提示：这个故事始于警察枪杀一名叫特伦斯·克拉彻（Terence Crutcher）的男子，并且在整集节目中都会讨论警察针对非裔美国人的暴力行为。在2016年9的一个傍晚，特伦斯·克鲁彻的SUV停在俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨市的一条马路中间。一名妇女看到他从车里走出来。车门开着，发动机还在运转。这位妇女拨打了911。警官贝蒂·谢尔比（Betty Shelby）在接到这个求助电话时，正赶去处理一件毫不相干的事件。
Terrence was 40, African-American, born and raised in Tulsa. He was a church-going man with four children. Betty was 42, white, a mother. She was born in a small town not far from Tulsa. In an ideal world, these two Oklahoma natives, close in age, ought to have had more to bring them together than hold them apart. But on this evening, there was no small talk or friendly chatter. The police officer told Terence to take his hands out of his pockets.
特伦斯40岁，是非裔美国人，在塔尔萨出生长大。他是一个经常去教堂的人，育有四个孩子。贝蒂42岁，是白人，也是一位母亲。她出生在离塔尔萨不远的一个小镇上。在理想的世界里，这两个年龄相仿、土生土长的俄克拉荷马州人，应该有更多的共同点将他们凝聚在一起，而不是让他们疏远。但在这个傍晚，没有任何闲聊或友好的交谈。这位女警官命令特伦斯把手从口袋里拿出来。
According to her attorney, he first complied. He then put his hands up in the air. Moments later, he put his hands back in his pockets. By this point, multiple police officers had gathered and drawn their guns and tasers. Overhead, a police chopper filmed events as they unfolded. From the video, it's hard to tell exactly what's happening on the ground, but an officer in the helicopter thinks Terrence is not cooperating. Not for taser, I think.
根据她的律师所说，他起先照做了。然后他把双手举在空中。片刻之后，他又把手放回了口袋里。此时，多名警察已经聚集过来，并拔出了他们的枪和泰瑟枪。头顶上，一架警用直升机记录了事态的发展。从视频中很难看出地面上到底发生了什么，但直升机上的一名警察认为特伦斯并不配合。“我觉得不用泰瑟枪。”
That looks like a bad dude too. To be honest, I'll tell you. Moments later, one officer on the ground does fire a taser. Betty Shelby fires her gun. God fired! Oh, 321, we have shot fire. We have one set set down. We need an insulator.
“这家伙看起来也很危险。老实说，我跟你讲。”片刻之后，地面上的一名警察确实发射了一台泰瑟枪。贝蒂·谢尔比开枪了。“开枪了！哦，321，我们开火了。我们击倒了一个。我们需要一个电击器。”
She kills Terence Croucher. Later, police discover that he was unarmed. At a press conference after the shooting, a journalist asked Cot Wood Betty Shelby's attorney why she opened fire. Did him being a big black man play a role in her perceived danger? No, him being a large man perceived a role in her being in danger. She's worked in this part of town for quite some time. And, you know, just the week before,
她杀死了特伦斯·克鲁彻。后来，警察发现他是赤手空拳的。在枪击事件发生后的新闻发布会上，一名记者问贝蒂·谢尔比的律师科特·伍德（Cot Wood）她为什么要开枪。“他是个身材高大的黑人男子，这在她感受到的危险中起了作用吗？”“不，是他是一个身材高大的人，这在她感到危险中起到了作用。她在这个镇上的这个片区工作了相当长的一段时间。而且，你知道，就在前一个星期，”
she was at an all black high school homecoming football game. She's not afraid of black people. Terrence Croucher's sister Tiffany sees it very differently. She thinks the officer shot her brother because he was black. That big bad dude was my twin brother. That big bad dude was a father. That big bad dude was a son. That big bad dude was enrolled at Tulsa Community College.
她还去参加了一所全黑人高中的返校节橄榄球赛。她并不害怕黑人。特伦斯·克鲁彻的姐姐蒂芬妮（Tiffany）看法完全不同。她认为这位警官开枪打死她弟弟是因为他是黑人。“那个高大凶猛的家伙是我的双胞胎弟弟。那个高大凶猛的家伙是一位父亲。那个高大凶猛的家伙是一个儿子。那个高大凶猛的家伙是塔尔萨社区学院的学生。”
Just wanting to make us proud. Betty Shelby's daughter Amber, That big bad dude was enrolled at Tulsa Community College. Just wanting to make us proud. Betty Shelby's daughter Amber defended her mother. I am here to reveal to you the side of my mother that the public does not know. My mother is an incredible, supportive, loving and caring woman. She is a wife, a mother, and a grandmother, with a heart of gold. She has always fought for the underdog and stands up for the weak. Betty Shelby was acquitted of manslaughter charges. Still, the tenor of the back and forth,
“只是想让我们骄傲。”贝蒂·谢尔比的女儿安珀（Amber）为她的母亲辩护。“我来这里是为了向公众展示我母亲不为人知的一面。我母亲是一个不可思议、支持他人、充满爱心和关怀的女性。她是一位妻子、母亲和祖母，有着一颗金子般的心。她一直在为弱势群体战斗，为弱者挺身而出。”贝蒂·谢尔比的过失杀人罪名被判无罪。尽管如此，这种针锋相对的基调——
the psychological accusations and psychological defenses, is very revealing. When an incident like this occurs, we want to hear the story of what happened. We want to know what was going on in the mind of the shooter and the mind of the victim. Was Terence Croucher truly a threat? Did Betty Shelby dislike black people? What clues explain the behavior of these individuals? We home in, dig for facts, and look for psychological explanations. But what if there is another way to think about what happened, one that has less to do with the individuals involved, and more to do with the context in which the shooting occurred?
心理上的指责和心理上的辩护——非常具有启示性。当这样的事件发生时，我们想要听听到底发生了什么的故事。我们想知道开枪者和受害者的心中在想什么。特伦斯·克鲁彻真的构成了威胁吗？贝蒂·谢尔比不喜欢黑人吗？有什么线索可以解释这些人的行为？我们深入钻研，寻找事实，并寻求心理学上的解释。但是，如果还有另一种方式来思考所发生的事情呢？这种方式与涉事个体的关系较小，而与枪击事件发生的背景有更多关联？
What we're discovering here is that the individual mind sits in society and the connection between mind and society is an extremely important one that should not be forgotten. Individual behavior and the mind of the village this week on Hidden Brain. I'm Maserine Banaji. Maserine is a psychology professor at Harvard. She's made a career out of studying the invisible. For the past 30 years, I've been interested in studying those aspects of our minds that are hidden from our own conscious awareness.
我们在这里发现的是，个体的思维存在于社会之中，而思维与社会之间的连接是一个极其重要且不容忽视的连接。个体行为与村庄的思维，本周《隐藏的大脑》。我是马瑟琳·巴纳吉（Mahzarin Banaji）。马瑟琳是哈佛大学的一名心理学教授。她的大部分职业生涯都在研究隐形的事物。在过去的30年中，我一直对研究我们大脑中对我们自己的有意识觉察隐藏起来的那些方面感兴趣。
Maserine's interests began in graduate school. She was teaching psychology at Yale and looking for a way to measure people's biases. There was debate over the right scientific method to do this. You could simply ask people their views, but because prejudice is a sensitive topic, you often don't get anything. You couldn't walk up to somebody and say, do you agree that Italians are lazy and have them say, yes or no? they'll just refuse to answer that question. Our deep-seated discomfort about discussing prejudice was one hurdle for a researcher looking to study the phenomenon.
马瑟琳的兴趣始于研究生院。她当时在耶鲁大学教心理学，并寻找一种测量人们偏见的方法。关于实现这一目标的正确科学方法曾存在争议。你可以直接询问人们的观点，但由于偏见是一个敏感话题，你往往得不到任何结果。你不能走到某个人面前说：“你同意意大利人很懒吗？”然后让他们回答“是”或“否”。他们只会拒绝回答这个问题。我们对讨论偏见根深蒂固的不适感，是研究这一现象的研究人员面临的障碍之一。
Maserine realized there was another barrier. What if some forms of prejudice are so deeply buried that people don't even realize they harbor such bias? Perhaps we behave in ways that are not known to our own conscious awareness, that we are being driven to act in certain ways, not because we're explicitly prejudiced, but because we make Harry in our heads the thumbprint of the culture. Was there a way to decipher this thumbprint and expose people's hidden biases?
马瑟琳意识到还有另一个障碍。如果某些形式的偏见埋藏得如此之深，以至于人们甚至没有意识到自己怀有这种偏见呢？也许我们的行为方式是我们自己的有意识觉察所不知道的，我们被驱使着以某种方式行事，不是因为我们明确抱有偏见，而是因为我们在头脑中将文化的指纹刻了进去。有没有一种方法可以解读这个指纹并暴露人们隐藏的偏见呢？
Eventually, Maserine, with the help of her mentor Tony Greenwald, and then graduate student Brian Nosek, developed a simple, ingenious test. It's called the implicit association test or the IAT. It's based on the way we group things in our minds. When you say bread, my mind will easily think butter, but not something unrelated to it. Like say, a hammer. Our brains, it turns out, make associations, and these associations can reveal important things about the way we think. So the way the IAT works is to simply ask people to sort things.
最终，马瑟琳在她的导师托尼·格林沃尔德（Tony Greenwald）以及当时的研究生布莱恩·诺塞克（Brian Nosek）的帮助下，开发了一个简单而巧妙的测试。它被称为隐式联想测验，即IAT。它基于我们在脑海中将事物分组的方式。当你经说出“面包”时，我的大脑会很自然地联想到“黄油”，而不是与之无关的东西。比如，一把锤子。事实证明，我们的大脑会产生联想，而这些联想可以揭示关于我们思维方式的重要信息。因此，IAT的工作原理就是简单地要求人们对事物进行分类。
So imagine that you're given a deck of playing cards, and you're asked to sort all the red cards to the left and all the black cards to the right. I'll predict that it will take you about 20 seconds to run through that deck. Next, Mazarin says, shuffle the deck and resort the cards. This time, I'd like you to put all the spades and the diamonds to one side and the clubs and the hearts to the other side.
所以，想象一下，给你一副扑克牌，要求你把所有的红牌分到左边，把所有的黑牌分到右边。我敢说，你大概只需要20秒就能把这副牌理完。接着，马瑟琳说，把牌洗匀，重新分类。这一次，我希望你把所有的黑桃和方块放在一边，把所有的梅花和红心放在另一边。
And what we'll find is that this will take you nearly twice as long to do. Why? Because a rule that your brain had learned, red and red go together, black and black go together is no longer available to you. Remember that in both scenarios, you are grouping two suits together. In the first scenario, you are grouping hearts with diamonds and clubs with spades. In the second scenario, you are grouping hearts with clubs and diamonds with spades. Because there's a simple rule for the first task, group red with red and black with black, that task is easy. In the second scenario, you need a fraction
而我们会发现，你做这件事需要花将近两倍的时间。为什么？因为你大脑已经学会的一个规则——红色和红色归为一类，黑色和黑色归为一类——对你来说不再适用了。请记住，在这两种情况下，你都是把两种花色归为一组。在第一种情况下，你把红心和方块分在一组，梅花和黑桃分在一组。在第二种情况下，你把红心和梅花分在一组，方块和黑桃分在一组。因为第一个任务有一个简单的规则，即红色与红色归为一组，黑色与黑色归为一组，所以这个任务很简单。在第二种情况下，你需要花一小部分
of a second to think about each card. You can't follow a simple rule of thumb. Mazurine and Tony and Brian had an important insight. These rules of association apply to many subjects, including the way we think about other human beings. So they created a new sorting task. Sort for me, faces of black people and bad things together, words like devil and bomb and vomit and awful and failure. Sort those on one side of the playing deck. On the other side, put the faces of white people, and words like love and peace and joy and sunshine and friendly and so on to the other side. This turns out to be pretty easy for us to do because as my colleagues and I will argue the association of white and good and black and bad has been made for us in our culture.
秒钟来思考每一张牌。你不能遵循一个简单的经验法则。马瑟琳、托尼和布莱恩有一个重要的见解。这些联想规则适用于许多主题，包括我们对其他人类的看法。于是他们创造了一个新的分类任务。为我把黑人的面孔和不好的事物归为一组，比如恶魔、炸弹、呕吐物、糟糕和失败这些词。把这些放在扑克牌的一边。在另一边，放上白人的面孔，以及诸如爱、和平、喜悦、阳光、友好等词语放在另一边。事实证明，这对我们来说很容易做到，因为正如我和我的同事们所论证的那样，白人与好、黑人与坏的联想已经在我们的文化中为我们做好了。
The test doesn't end there. After sorting white and good into one group and black and bad into another, you now have to do it again, this time grouping black with good and white with bad. And when you try to do that and when I try to do that, the data show that we will slow down, that we can't do it quite as fast because black and good are not practice responses for us. They're not habitual responses for us. We have to exert control to make that happen because it doesn't come naturally and easily to us. That's the IAT. By the way, if you're wondering whether the order of the test makes a difference, it doesn't.
测试并没有到此结束。在将白人和好归为一组、黑人和坏归为另一组之后，你现在必须再做一次，这一次要把黑人和好归为一组，把白人和坏归为一组。当你试图这样做以及当我试图这样做时，数据表明我们会放慢速度，我们无法做得那么快，因为黑人和好对我们来说不是经过练习的反应。它们对我们来说不是习惯性的反应。我们必须施加控制来让它发生，因为它对我们来说并不是自然而然、轻而易举的。这就是IAT。顺便说一句，如果你在想测试的顺序是否有影响，答案是没有。
The researchers have presented tests to volunteers in different ways. It doesn't make a difference if you ask people to first group black with bad or first ask them to group black with good. In both cases, people are faster to associate white faces with positive words and black faces with negative words. Maserine thinks the IAT is measuring a form of bias that is implicit or unconscious. Mazarin herself has taken the IAT many times. To her dismay, the test shows she has robust levels of unconscious bias. My brain simply could not make the association of black with good as quickly as I could make the association of white, with good. And that told me something, it told me, it's not the IAT that screwed up, it's my head
研究人员以不同的方式向志愿者展示了测试。要求人们首先将黑色与坏归为一组，还是首先要求他们将黑色与好归为一组，并没有什么区别。在这两种情况下，人们都更快地将白人面孔与积极词汇联系起来，将黑色面孔与消极词汇联系起来。马瑟琳认为IAT正在测量一种隐性的或无意识的偏见形式。马瑟琳自己也多次参加过IAT测试。令她沮丧的是，测试显示她拥有高度的无意识偏见。我的大脑就是无法像建立白人与好的联想那样快地建立黑色与好的联想。这告诉我一些事情，它告诉我，出问题的不是IAT，而是我的脑袋
that screwed up. Because the IAT is a timed test, the results can be precisely measured. Implicit bias, in other words, can be quantified. Most psychological tests are only available in the lab, but Marzareen and her colleagues decided to do something radical. They put their test on the internet. You can find it today at implicit.harvard.edu. Millions of people have taken this test.
出问题了。因为IAT是一个计时测试，所以结果可以被精确测量。换句话说，隐性偏见是可以被量化的。大多数心理学测试只能在实验室里进行，但马瑟琳和她的同事们决定做一件激进的事。他们把测试放到了互联网上。你今天可以在implicit.harvard.edu上找到它。数百万人参加了这项测试。
The data has been collected, shared, disseminated. The IAT is widely considered today to be the most influential test of unconscious bias. As Maserine and Tony and Brian were developing the IAT, other researchers were developing different ways to measure bias. Psychologist Joshua Corral found himself diving into the field shortly after a black man was shot and killed in New York City in 1999. His name, Amadou Diallo. Diallo was standing unarmed on the front stoop of his apartment building and the police
数据已被收集、共享、传播。今天，IAT被广泛认为是评估无意识偏见最具影响力的测试。正当马瑟琳、托尼和布莱恩开发IAT时，其他研究人员也在开发测量偏见的不同方法。心理学家约书亚·科雷尔（Joshua Correll）发现自己深入研究这一领域，是在1999年纽约市一名黑人男子被枪杀之后。他的名字叫阿马杜·迪亚洛（Amadou Diallo）。迪亚洛当时赤手空拳地站在他公寓楼的前门台阶上，警察
thought he looked suspicious and they approached him and they ended up shooting him and the question that everybody was asking, and this was, I mean, something that people, you know, across the country were wondering about was he shot because he was black. At the time, Joshua was starting graduate school. I took that question pretty seriously, and we tried to figure out how we could test it in a laboratory. Joshua and his colleagues eventually developed a video game.
觉得他看起来很可疑，于是走近他，最终向他开枪。每个人都在问的问题是——这意味着人们，你知道的，全国各地的人都在纳闷的事情——他被枪杀是因为他是黑人吗？当时，约书亚刚开始读研究生。“我非常严肃地对待这个问题，我们试图找出如何在实验室里对其进行测试。”约书亚和他的同事们最终开发了一个电子游戏。
It was a pretty bad video game, but it did the trick. It's more like a slideshow where there are a series of backgrounds that pop up on the screen, and then in one of those critical backgrounds, a person will suddenly appear. So we've got photographs of, say, 25 or so white men and 25 black men, and we've photographed these guys holding a variety of different objects. Cell phones, can a coke, a wallet, a silver pistol, a black pistol, and so we've
这其实是个挺烂的电子游戏，但它确实达到了目的。它更像是一个幻灯片放映，屏幕上会弹出一系列背景，然后在一个关键背景中，一个人会突然出现。所以我们有大约25张白人男性的照片和25张黑人男性的照片，我们拍摄了这些人拿着各种不同物体的照片。手机、一罐可乐、钱包、银色手枪、黑色手枪，因此我们
just edited the photographs so that the person pops up in the background holding an object and the player has to decide how to respond and they're instructed if the guy on the screen has a gun, he's a bad guy and you're supposed to shoot him and you're supposed to do that as quickly as you possibly can. What Joshua wanted to know was whether players would respond differently depending on the race of the target on the screen. Say a black guy pops up holding a wallet and a white guy pops up holding a wallet, what's the likelihood that the black guy gets shot and the white guy doesn't? If current events are any clue, you may guess the answer. Here we're looking at, say, you know, the player is responding to a target who's holding
只是编辑了这些照片，让这个人出现在背景中手里拿着一个物体，而玩家必须决定如何做出反应。他们的指令是：如果屏幕上的家伙有枪，他就是个坏家伙，你应该射杀他，而且你必须以最快的速度完成。约书亚想知道的是，玩家是否会根据屏幕上目标种族的改变而做出不同的反应。比如一个黑人跳出来手里拿着一个钱包，和一个白人跳出来手里拿着一个钱包，黑人被枪击而白人不被枪击的可能性有多大？如果时事能提供任何线索，你大概能猜到答案。在这里，我们看到的是，比方说，玩家正在对一个手里拿着
a wallet, and the correct decision is to say don't shoot, and what we found is that they are faster to say don't shoot, if the target is white rather than black. The same hell true for arm targets. Test takers were faster to shoot black targets, slow out a shoot, white ones. Now, you might think that Joshua would conclude that his test takers were just racist. But one important similarity between Joshua's test
钱包的目标做出反应，正确的决定是说“不要开枪”，而我们发现的是，如果目标是白人而不是黑人，他们会更快地做出“不要开枪”的反应。对于持武器的目标，情况同样如此。测试者对黑色目标的射击速度更快，对白色目标的射击速度则较慢。现在，你可能会认为约书亚得出的结论是他的测试参与者只是种族主义者。但约书亚的测试
and Maasareens test is that they do not presume that the people with such biases have active animosity toward African Americans. These are not members of the Ku Klux Klan. the people with such biases have active animosity toward African-Americans. These are not members of the Ku Klux Klan. It was just exactly what we had predicted. And I guess both kind of hoped and feared, right? I mean, it's an exciting scientific moment,
与马瑟琳的测试之间的一个重要相似之处在于，他们并不假定具有这种偏见的人对非裔美国人抱有积极的敌意。这些人不是三K党成员。这些人对非裔美国人抱有积极的敌意。这些人不是三K党成员。这完全符合我们的预测。我想大家既抱有希望又感到恐惧，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个激动人心的科学时刻，
but it also suggests something kind of deeply troubling that these participants who are presumably nice people with no bone to pick. They're not bigots, they're not angry at black people in any way, but what we saw in their data very very clearly is an tendency to associate black people with threat and to shoot them more quickly. You can see that both the psychological tests are academic exercises. Do they see anything about how people behave in real life? Joshua Corral is very clear that his video game experiment cannot replicate real life.
但它也暗示了一些非常令人深感不安的事情，即这些参与者大概是很好的人，与任何人都没有宿怨。他们不是偏执狂，他们对黑人在任何方面都没有愤怒，但在他们的数据中，我们非常非常清楚地看到了一种将黑人与威胁联系起来并更快地向他们开枪的倾向。你可以看到，这两个心理学测试都是学术练习。它们能说明人们在现实生活中的行为方式吗？约书亚·科雷尔非常明确地表示，他的电子游戏实验无法复制现实生活。
It's impossible, he says, to recreate in a lab the fear and stress that a real world police confrontation can generate. The IAT2 has been criticized for a somewhat hazy link between test results and real world behavior. Hundreds of studies have been conducted looking at whether the IAT explains or predicts how people will act. The results have been mixed. In some studies, unconscious racial bias on the test seems to predict how people will
他说，在实验室里重现现实世界中警察对峙所能产生的恐惧和压力是不可能的。IAT也因测试结果与现实世界行为之间的联系有些模糊而受到批评。人们进行了数百项研究，以探讨IAT是否能解释或预测人们的行为方式。结果毁誉参半。在一些研究中，测试中的无意识种族偏见似乎可以预测人们的行为方式
behave. Research has found, for example, that doctors who score high and implicit bias are less likely to prescribe clot-pusting heart drugs to black patients compared to white patients. But other studies, also looking at doctors and black and white patients, find no correlation between results on the bias test and actual behavior. This discrepancy bothers psychologists Phil Tetlock at the University of Pennsylvania. He is a critic of the IAT.
会怎样。例如，研究发现，在隐性偏见测试中得分较高的医生，与白人患者相比，向黑人患者开具溶栓心脏药物的可能性更小。但其他同样研究医生以及黑人和白人患者的研究发现，偏见测试的结果与实际行为之间没有相关性。这种差异让宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克（Phil Tetlock）感到困扰。他是IAT的批评者。
It's a test that is enormously intuitively appealing. I've never seen a psychological test take off the way the IAT has and it's gripped the popular imagination the way it has because it just seems on its surface to be measuring something like prejudice. Tetlock and other critics are concerned that just because someone shows bias on the IAT doesn't mean that they're going to act in biased ways in real life. If a test cannot predict how you're going to act, isn't it just an academic exercise? There is the question of whether or not people who score as prejudiced on the IAT actually
这是一个在直觉上极具吸引力的测试。我从未见过哪个心理学测试能像IAT这样腾飞，它之所以抓住了大众的想象力，是因为它表面上看起来似乎在衡量类似偏见的东西。泰特洛克和其他批评者担心，仅仅因为某人在IAT上表现出偏见，并不意味着他们在现实生活中会以带有偏见的方式行事。如果一个测试无法预测你将如何行动，那它不就只是一项学术练习吗？这里存在一个问题，即在IAT上被评为有偏见的人是否真的
act in the discriminatory ways toward other human beings in real world situations. And if they don't, if there is very close to zero relationship between those two things, what exactly is the IIT measuring? It turns out a lot. There's new evidence that suggests the IIT does in fact predict behavior. But to see it, you have to zoom out. You have to widen the lens to look beyond the individual and into the community. Hello, my name is Eric Haman.
在现实世界的情境中对其他人采取歧视性的行为。如果他们不这样，如果这两者之间的关系接近于零，那么IAT到底在测量什么？事实证明，测量的内容很多。有新的证据表明，IAT实际上确实能够预测行为。但要看到这一点，你必须缩小视野。你必须拓宽镜头，超越个体，放眼社区。你好，我叫埃里克·海曼（Eric Hehman）。
He's a psychology professor at McGill University. Eric got interested in the IAT as he was researching the use of lethal force in policing. He was trying to design a statistical model that would predict where in the United States, people of color are disproportionately likely to be shot and killed by police. First, he needed some baseline data. This proved hard since the federal government
他是麦吉尔大学（McGill University）的一名心理学教授。埃里克在研究警务工作中致命武力的使用时，开始对IAT产生兴趣。他试图设计一个统计模型，用来预测在美国的什么地方，有色人种更有可能不成比例地遭到警察的枪击和杀害。首先，他需要一些基线数据。事实证明这很难，因为联邦政府
does not require police departments to report deadly shootings by officers. We really had no idea about really basic questions, such as how often they were happening, where they were happening, and who they were happening to. But in 2015, some news outlets, including the Washington Post and the British newspaper The Guardian, began to compile their own database on police homicides
并不要求警察局报告警员的致命枪击事件。我们对一些非常基础的问题确实一无所知，比如这些事件发生的频率、发生的地点以及受害者是谁。但在2015年，一些新闻媒体，包括《华盛顿邮报》和英国《卫报》，开始汇编他们自己的数据库，记录警察杀人事件
in the United States. According to official terminology, these are called justifiable homicides. So what they were putting together was the most comprehensive list of these justifiable homicides in the United States. Eric used this data to pinpoint where disproportionate police shootings of minorities were most likely. Then he turned to the IAT data. Eric suspected that if bias was a factor in police shootings, it was likely that implicit bias, rather than overt racism, was at play.
在美国。根据官方术语，这些被称为“正当杀戮”。所以他们汇编的是美国这些正当杀戮中最全面的清单。埃里克利用这些数据来精确定位少数族群更有可能遭到警察不成比例枪击的地方。然后他转向了IAT数据。埃里克怀疑，如果偏见是警察枪击事件的一个因素，那么起作用的可能是不显性的隐性偏见，而不是公开的种族主义。
Traditionally, the field has found that explicit biases are predict behaviors that are under our conscious control, whereas implicit biases predict things are a little bit more automatic, a little bit more difficult to control. And this is exactly the sort of behavior that we thought might be involved in police shootings.
传统上，该领域发现，显性偏见可以预测那些受我们有意识控制的行为，而隐性偏见则可以预测一些稍微更具自动性、更难以控制的事情。而这正是我们认为可能与警察枪击事件有关的那类行为。
People take the IAT anonymously, but they need to provide some information like their race and where they live. With the millions of data points the IAT provided, Eric painted a map of bias across the United States. Some places seem to have lots of bias. Others very little. Now he had two databases. He cross-reference them to see if there was any connection between communities with disproportionate numbers of police shootings of minorities and communities
人们匿名参加IAT，但他们需要提供一些信息，比如他们的种族和居住地。凭借IAT提供的数百万个数据点，埃里克绘制了一张美国各地的偏见地图。有些地方似乎有很大的偏见，有些地方则非常少。现在他有了两个数据库。他将它们进行交叉引用，以查看少数族人群体枪击事件不成比例的社区与
showing high levels of implicit bias. A powerful correlation emerged. So we find that in communities in which people have more racial biases, African-Americans are being killed more by police than their presence in the population would warrant. Let me repeat this because it's important. In places where implicit bias in a community is higher than average, police shootings of minorities are also higher than average, police shootings of minorities are also higher than average. Erics analysis effectively pinpoints where police shootings are likely to happen. But here's what makes the finding crazy. Most people who take the IAT are not police officers.
显示出高水平隐性偏见的社区之间是否存在任何联系。一个强有力的相关性浮现了。因此我们发现，在人们具有更多种族偏见的社区中，非裔美国人被警察杀害的人数超出了其人口占比应有的水平。让我重复一遍，因为这很重要。在社区隐性偏见高于平均水平的地方，针对少数族裔的警察枪击事件也高于平均水平，针对少数族裔的警察枪击事件也高于平均水平。埃里克的分析有效地精确定位了警察枪击事件可能发生的地方。但这项发现疯狂的地方在于：参加IAT的大多数人并不是警察。
So we're predicting police behavior by not measuring police at all themselves. Coming up, we explore how a test can predict how people will behave, even when they're not the people who take the test. Stay with us. The world is complicated, but knowing the past can help us understand it so much better. That's where we come in. I'm Randa Dutfata. I'm Ramti Nara Blui, and we're the host of Thru Line, MPR's History Podcast. Every week we'll dig into forgotten stories from the moments that shaped our world. Through line, from MPR, listen and subscribe now.
所以我们是通过根本没有对警察本身进行测量来预测警察的行为。接下来，我们将探讨一项测试如何能够预测人们将如何行动，即使他们并不是参加测试的人。请继续收听。世界很复杂，但了解过去能帮助我们更好地理解它。这就是我们登场的时候了。我是兰达·代夫法塔（Randa Dutfata）。我是拉姆蒂·纳拉布鲁伊（Ramti Nara Blui），我们是NPR历史播客《Thru Line》的主持人。每周我们将挖掘塑造我们世界的那些时刻中被遗忘的故事。来自NPR的《Thru Line》，现在就去收听并订阅吧。
Psychologist Eric Heyman found a way to predict police behavior by comparing places that have high levels of implicit bias with places where police shootings of minorities are higher than average. Since police don't typically take the IAT, how could the IAT be predicting how police would behave? Eric thinks the test has tapped into the mind of the community as a whole. Say there's a neighborhood that's traditionally
心理学家埃里克·海曼通过比较隐性偏见水平较高的地区与少数族裔警察枪击事件高于平均水平的地区，找到了一种预测警察行为的方法。既然警察通常不参加IAT测试，IAT怎么能预测警察会如何行动呢？埃里克认为，这项测试已经触及了整个社区的思维。比方说，有一个社区传统上
associated with threat or danger and the people who live in that neighborhood have these associations between African Americans and threat or African Americans and danger. And these would be anybody in this community. This could be my mother or the person who lives down the street, not necessarily the police officers themselves. But there's this idea that this attitude is pervasive
与威胁或危险联系在一起，而居住在这个社区的人们在非裔美国人与威胁之间，或者非裔美国人与危险之间存在这些联想。而这些人可以是这个社区中的任何人。这可能是我的母亲或住在街对面的人，不一定是警察本身。但这有一种观点认为，这种态度在整个地区是普遍存在的。
across the entire area. And that when officers are operating in that area, they themselves might share that same attitude, that might influence their behaviors in these split-second, challenging life and death decisions. Implicit bias is like the smog that hangs over a community. It becomes the air people breathe. Or as Mazerine might say, the thumbprint of the culture is showing up in the minds of the people living in that community. There are many examples for this idea that individual minds shape the community and the community shapes what happens in individual minds.
并且当警员在该地区执勤时，他们自己可能也持有这种相同的态度，这可能会影响他们在这些千钧一发、充满挑战的生死抉择中的行为。隐性偏见就像悬浮在社区上空的雾霾。它成了人们呼吸的空气。或者正如马瑟琳可能会说的那样，文化的指纹正显现在生活在该社区的人们的头脑中。对于“个体思维塑造社区，而社区塑造个体思维中发生的事情”这一观点，有很多例子。
Sets Stevens-Devitovitz is a data scientist who used to work at Google. In his book, Everybody Lies, Sets explains how big data from Google searches can predict with great accuracy, things like the suicide rate in a community, or the chances that a hate crime will take place. We've shown that you can predict hate crimes against Muslims based on searches people make. People make very, very, very disturbing searches, searches such as Kill Muslims or I hate Muslims.
塞茨·斯蒂芬斯-戴维维茨（Sets Stevens-Devitovitz）是一名曾就职于谷歌的数据科学家。在他的书《人人说谎》（Everybody Lies）中，塞茨解释了来自谷歌搜索的大数据如何能以极高的准确性预测诸如社区自杀率或仇恨犯罪发生概率等事情。我们已经证明，你可以根据人们进行的搜索来预测针对穆斯林的仇恨犯罪。人们进行了非常、非常、非常令人不安的搜索，例如“杀死穆斯林”或“我讨厌穆斯林”。
And these searches can predict on a given week how many hate crimes there will be against Muslims. But I think the right approach to this is not to target any particular individual to show up at the door of any particular individual who make these searches. But if there are many, many searches in a given week, it will be wise for police departments to put extra security around mosques because there is greater threat of these attacks. In other words, what the Google search data is doing is effectively taking the temperature of an entire community.
并且这些搜索可以预测在给定的一周内会有多少针对穆斯林的仇恨犯罪。但我认为正确的方法不是把目标锁定在任何特定的个人身上，不是跑到任何一个进行这些搜索的特定个人的家门口。但是，如果在给定的一周内有非常非常多的搜索，警察部门明智的做法是在清真寺周围增加安保，因为这些袭击的威胁更大。换句话说，谷歌搜索数据所做的事情，实际上是在测量整个社区的温度。
That's what you're really saying, that you're picking up on things that are in the ether if you will in the community that might not show up in the individual, but are likely to show up in the aggregate. Yeah, and I think you don't really know the reason that any particular person makes a search, right? Someone could be searching kill Muslims because they're doing research or they're just curious about something or they made a mistake and they're typing. There are a lot of reasons that an individual can make these searches.
这才是你真正想说的，你捕捉到了如果可以这么说的话，那些存在于社区空气中、可能不会在个人身上显现、但很可能会在总体上显现出来的东西。是的，而且我认为你真的不知道任何特定个人进行搜索的原因，对吧？有人可能会搜索“杀死穆斯林”，因为他们在做研究，或者他们只是对某事感到好奇，或者他们犯了个错误正在打字。个人进行这些搜索的原因有很多。
But if twice as many people are making these searches, well, if I were Muslim American, I'd want some extra security around my mosque, right? Asking whether implicit bias affects the behavior of every individual is a little like investigating everyone who types an offensive search term into Google. A lot of the time, you're going to find nothing. And yet, when you look at the use of search terms in aggregate, it can tell you with great precision, which areas will see the most hit crimes. For her part, Maazureen Banaji believes Eric's work is a key link between her psychological data on how individuals behave and sociological insights
但如果有两倍多的人在进行这些搜索，好吧，如果我是美籍穆斯林，我会希望我的清真寺周围有一些额外的安保，对吧？询问隐性偏见是否影响每个人的行为，有点像调查每一个在谷歌中输入攻击性搜索词的人。很多时候，你什么也找不到。然而，当你从总体上看待搜索词的使用时，它可以极其精确地告诉你哪些地区的仇恨犯罪最多。就她而言，马瑟琳·巴纳吉认为埃里克的工作是连接关于个体行为的心理学数据与关于社区行为的社会学洞察的关键桥梁。
on how community behaves. What we're discovering here is that the individual mind sits in society and the connection between mind and society is an extremely important one that should not be forgotten. And that more than any other group of people, social psychologists, owe it to the beginnings of their discipline, to do both and to do it even handedly, to be focused on the individual
我们在这里发现的是，个体的思维存在于社会之中，而思维与社会之间的连接是一个极其重要且不容忽视的连接。并且，与其他任何群体相比，社会心理学家理应回归其学科的初创精神，双管齐下、平衡地开展工作，既专注于个体
mind and to be talking about how that mind is both influenced by and is influencing the larger social group around her. This is why, says Maserine, when a problem has spread throughout a community, when it has become part of the culture, you can't fix it by simply focusing on individuals. One of the difficulties we've had in the past is that we have looked at individual people
思维，又要探讨这种思维是如何既受到她周围更大的社会群体的影响，又反过来影响该群体的。这就是为什么，马瑟琳说，当一个问题在整个社区蔓延开来、当它成为文化的一部分时，你不能仅仅通过关注个人来解决它。我们过去遇到的困难之一是，我们审视了个别的人
and blamed individual people. We've said, if we can remove these 10 bad police officers from this force, we'll be fine. And we know our social scientists, and I believe firmly that that is no way to change anything. This new way of thinking about bias showed up in the last presidential election. Democrat Hillary Clinton said implicit bias probably played a role in police shootings. I think implicit bias is a problem for everyone, not just police. I think unfortunately too many of us in our great country jumped to conclusions about each other. Republican Mike Pence, now Vice President, bristled at the idea.
并指责了个别的人。我们说过，如果我们能从这支警队中清除这10名糟糕的警察，我们就没事了。我们知道我们的社会科学家，而且我坚信，那根本不是改变任何事情的方法。这种关于偏见的新思维方式在上次总统大选中显现出来。民主党人希拉里·克林顿表示，隐性偏见可能在警察枪击事件中发挥了作用。“我认为隐性偏见对每个人来说都是一个问题，而不仅仅是警察。我认为不幸的是，在我们这个伟大的国家里，我们有太多人对彼此妄下结论。”共和党人迈克·彭斯（Mike Pence），现任副总统，对这一观点感到恼火。
He said that Clinton was calling cops racist. When African-American police officers involved in a police action shooting involving an African-American, why would Hillary Clinton accuse that African American police officer of him? I guess I can't believe you are defending a position that there is no bias. But as Mazarin says, it's not quite right to think of people with implicit bias as harboring the kind of racial hostility we typically think of when we say someone is a racist. Small kids show implicit bias. African Americans themselves show implicit bias against other African Americans.
他说克林顿是在指责警察是种族主义者。“当非裔美国警察卷入涉及非裔美国人的枪击执法行动时，希拉里·克林顿为什么要指责那个非裔美国警察？”我猜我无法相信你在捍卫“不存在偏见”这种立场。但正如马瑟琳所说，把带有隐性偏见的人视为怀有我们通常说某人是种族主义者时所想的那种种族敌意，是不太准确的。小孩子也会表现出隐性偏见。非裔美国人自己对其他非裔美国人也会表现出隐性偏见。
The test isn't picking up the nasty thoughts of a few angry outliers. It's picking up the thumbprint of the culture on each of our minds. So what can we do? Miserine is skeptical of those who offer training courses that promise quick fix solutions. There are many people across the country who say that they offer such a thing, called implicit by a training. And what they do is explain to large groups of people what might be going on that's keeping them from reaching their own goals and being the good people that they think they are. And my concern is that when I'm an old woman, that I will look back at this time and think, why didn't I do something about this because I don't believe this training is going to do anything?
这项测试捕捉到的不是几个愤怒的极端的恶劣想法。它捕捉到的是文化的指纹印在我们每个人头脑上的痕迹。那么我们能做些什么呢？马瑟琳对那些提供承诺快速解决问题的培训课程的人持怀疑态度。全国有许多人说他们提供这样一种东西，叫做“隐性偏见培训”。他们所做的是向大群人解释可能正在发生的事情，正是这些事情阻碍了他们实现自己的目标，无法成为他们自认为的好人。而我的担忧是，当我成为一个老妇人时，我会回首这段时间并想：我为什么不为此做点什么呢，因为我不相信这种培训会有任何用处？
In Mausoleen's view, you can't easily erase implicit bias because you can't erase the effect of the culture when people are living day in and day out in that same culture. But she and others argue that there might be ways to prevent such biases from influencing your behavior. Let's return to psychologist Joshua Correll. Remember, he created the active shooter video game that found test takers were more likely to shoot black targets rather than white ones. Many of Joshua's initial test takers were students. Eventually, he decided to see what would happen if police officers took the test.
在马瑟琳看来，你无法轻易消除隐性偏见，因为当人们日复一日地生活在同一种文化中时，你无法消除文化的影响。但她和其他人认为，或许有办法阻止此类偏见影响你的行为。让我们回到心理学家约书亚·科雷尔。请记住，他创建了活跃枪手电子游戏，发现测试参与者更有可能向黑色目标开枪，而不是白色目标。约书亚的许多初始测试参与者都是学生。最终，他决定看看如果警察参加测试会发生什么。
So he went to the Denver police. We brought down a bunch of laptops and button boxes, a bunch of electronic equipment that we were using to do this study, and we would set it up in their roll call room. And it was just complete chaos and really, really fun. And some of the police really wanted nothing to do with us, but a huge number of them volunteered and they wanted to talk with us afterwards. At first, the police officers performed exactly the same as everyone else. Their levels
于是他去了丹佛警察局。“我们带了一堆笔记本电脑和按键盒，一堆用于做这项研究的电子设备，我们把它安装在他们的点名室里。那简直是一团糟，但真的非常有趣。有些警察根本不想搭理我们，但有极多的人自愿参加，他们还想在事后跟我们聊聊。”起初，警官们的表现和其他所有人完全一样。他们
of implicit bias were about the same as laypeople who take the test, both in response times and in mistakes. But when it came to the actual shooting of targets, the police were very different. The police officers did not show a bias in who they actually shot. Those early test takers, college students and other lay people, displayed their bias on response time, mistakes, and who they shot. Not the police. But whereas those stereotypes may influence the behavior of the college students and of you and me, the police officers are somehow able to exert control.
的隐性偏见水平与参加测试的平民大致相同，无论是在反应时间还是在错误率上。但当涉及到对目标的实际射击时，警察表现得非常不同。警官们在他们实际射击的目标上没有表现出偏见。那些早期的测试参与者——大学生和其他平民——在反应时间、错误和他们射击的对象上都表现出了他们的偏见。警察则没有。然而，尽管这些刻板印象可能会影响大学生以及你我的行为，但警官们不知何故能够施加控制。
So even though the stereotype, say of threat, may come to mind, the officer can overcome that stereotype and respond based on the information that's actually present in the scene rather than information that the officer is bringing to it through his or her stereotypes. Joshua wondered whether there were certain factors that might keep police officers from exerting this kind of cognitive control
因此，尽管诸如“威胁”之类的刻板印象可能会浮现在脑海中，但警官能够克服这种刻板印象，并根据现场实际呈现的信息做出反应，而不是根据警官通过他或她的刻板印象带入现场的信息做出反应。约书亚想知道，是否存在某些因素可能会阻止警官对他们的偏见施加这种认知控制。
over their biases. He found, among other things, that sleep made a difference. Those who were getting less sleep were more likely to show racial bias in their decisions to shoot. And again, that's just consistent with this idea that they might be able to exert control to use cognitive resources to avoid showing stereotypic bias in their decisions, but when those resources are compromised, they can't
他发现，除其他因素外，睡眠会产生影响。睡眠较少的人在做开枪决定时更有可能表现出种族偏见。再说一次，这与这种观点完全一致：他们也许能够施加控制以利用认知资源来避免在决策中表现出刻板偏见，但当这些资源受损时，他们就无法
do it. They could be compromised in a variety of ways. Sleep is just one way that we can compromise it. This, once again, is evidence that you can't train people not to have unconscious bias. But as Joshua suggests, you can do things to make it less likely that people will be affected by their bias. To be clear, Joshua's experiments are laboratory experiments. We know in real life that beat police officers do shoot people in error.
做到这一点。它们可能会以各种方式受损。睡眠只是我们可能损害它的众多方式之一。这再次证明，你无法通过培训教会人们不要产生无意识偏见。但正如约书亚所建议的，你可以做一些事情，使人们不那么容易受到自身偏见的影响。需要明确的是，约书亚的实验是实验室实验。我们在现实生活中知道，巡警确实会错误地开枪。
Now this could be because, in a real life encounter, stuff happens that makes it very difficult for you to actually think about what you're doing. So on the street, when somebody pulls a gun on you, it's scary, right? Like, cops when they're involved in these firefights report some crazy, crazy psychological distortions because they're legitimately freaked out. If they think somebody poses a life and death threat, they may panic, and it may be hard to bring those cognitive resources online. In several recent high-profile cases, as with the case of Terence
现在这可能是因为，在现实生活中的遭遇中，会发生一些事情，让你很难去真正思考你在做什么。因此，在街上，当有人对你拔枪时，这很可怕，对吧？例如，警察当他们卷入这些枪战时，会报告一些疯狂的、疯狂的心理扭曲，因为他们确实被吓坏了。如果他们认为某人构成了生死威胁，他们可能会惊慌失措，而将这些认知资源调动上线可能会很困难。在最近几个备受瞩目的案件中，正如特伦斯
Croucher and Betty Shelby, police officers shoot people who are unarmed. Of course, officers do not always know whether someone is armed, it's only in hindsight that we know the officer was or wasn't in real danger. Joshua's larger point is that police encounters can be inherently stressful. The uncertainty embedded in a confrontation can make it very difficult to think objectively. To put it another way, if you're running a police department and want to reduce errors and shootings, it may be less useful to give cops a lecture on how they shouldn't be racist and more useful to build procedures that give cops an extra half second when they're making decisions under pressure.
·克鲁彻和贝蒂·谢尔比的案件一样，警察向手无寸铁的人开枪。当然，警官并不总是知道某人是否携带武器，只有在事后诸葛亮的情况下，我们才知道警官当时是否真的处于危险之中。约书亚更广泛的观点是，警察的遭遇本质上可能是充满压力的。对峙中固有的不确定性会使人很难进行客观思考。换句话说，如果你在管理一个警察局并希望减少错误和枪击事件，给警察上一堂关于他们不应该种族主义的课可能收效甚微，而建立一些程序，在警察在压力下做出决定时给他们额外半秒钟的时间，可能会更有用。
With practice and a bit of time to exercise conscious control, people can reduce the risk of falling prey to their implicit biases. There is the potential to control it, right? The performance of the regular police officers, or even people that we train in our lab lab suggests that people don't have to succumb to those stereotypic influences. They can exert control in certain circumstances. Maserine Banagee has a similar solution. She thinks we need more of what she calls in the moment reminders. For example, it's been found that some doctors prescribe pain killers
通过练习和一点时间来行使有意识的控制，人们可以降低落入内隐偏见陷阱的风险。我们是有潜力控制它的，对吧？普通警官的表现，甚至我们在实验室里训练过的人的表现都表明，人们不必屈服于那些刻板印象的影响。他们在某些情况下可以施加控制。马泽琳·班纳吉也有类似的解决方案。她认为我们需要更多她所说的即时提醒。例如，人们发现有些医生开止痛药
to white patients far more often than they do to black patients who are reporting exactly the same levels of pain. The only difference is the patient's skin color. This suggests that bias is at work. Maserine says if the bias is implicit, meaning physicians are acting biased without intending to be biased, a timely reminder can help doctors exercise cognitive control over their unconscious associations. You type in a painkiller that you want to prescribe to a patient into your electronic system while the patient is sitting next to you. And it seems to me quite simple that when you type in the name of any painkiller, let's say, codine, that a little graph pops up
给白人患者的频率远高于给那些报告疼痛程度完全相同的黑人患者。唯一的区别是患者的皮肤颜色。这表明偏见正在起作用。马泽琳说，如果偏见是内隐的，这意味着医生在没有意图偏见的情况下表现出偏见，及时的提醒可以帮助医生对他们的无意识联想进行认知控制。当患者坐在你旁边时，你在电子系统中输入你想给患者开的止痛药。在我看来，这很简单，当你输入任何止痛药的名字，比方说，可待因，就会弹出一个小图表
in front of you that says, please note, in our hospital system, we have noticed that this is the average amount of painkiller we give to white men. This is the average amount we give to black men for the same reported level of pain. In other words, giving doctors an opportunity to stop for a second to make a decision consciously and deliberately,
在你面前，上面写着，请注意，在我们的医院系统中，我们注意到这是我们给白人男性的平均止痛药剂量。这是我们针对相同报告疼痛程度给黑人男性的平均剂量。换句话说，让医生有机会停顿一秒钟，有意识、审慎地做出决定，
instead of quickly and automatically, this can reduce the effects of implicit bias. Psychology has spent many years understanding the behavior of individuals, but tools such as the IAT might give us away to understand communities as a whole. Maybe even countries as a whole. We did a study some years ago, Brian Nosek led this particular project in which we looked
而不是快速且自动地做出决定，这可以减少内隐偏见的影响。心理学花了多年时间来理解个体的行为，但诸如IAT（内隐联想测验）之类的工具可能会为我们提供一种理解整个社区的方法。甚至可能是整个国家。几年前我们做过一项研究，布赖恩·诺塞克领导了这个特定的项目，我们在其中考察了
at gender stereotypes across many countries in the world. How strongly do we associate female with science and male with science. And then we looked at the performance of girls and boys, roughly around eighth grade on some kind of a standardized test. And what we discovered is that the stronger the gender bias in a country, that is to say the stronger the association of male with science in a country, the less well girls in that country did on that mathematics test. That's very similar to the Haman kind of result because we didn't measure the gender bias in the girls and the boys who took the test. We were measuring something at the level of a country in that case.
世界上许多国家的性别刻板印象。我们将女性与科学以及男性与科学联系得有多紧密。然后我们观察了女孩和男孩在八年级左右在某种标准化测试中的表现。我们发现，一个国家的性别偏见越强，也就是说，一个国家将男性与科学的联系越强，该国女孩在数学测试中的表现就越差。这与海曼式的结果非常相似，因为我们没有测量参加测试的女孩和男孩的性别偏见。在那种情况下，我们测量的是国家层面的东西。
And yet, it did predict something systematic about the difference in performance between boys and girls. When we look at an event like a police shooting, we invariably seek to understand it at the level of individuals. If something bad happens, we think it has to be because someone had bad intentions. Implicit bias certainly does act on individuals, but it's possible that its strongest effects are at the level of a community as a whole. This might be why some police shootings of African-American men are carried out by African-American police officers, and why some physicians who are not prescribing pain medications to people of color might themselves be people of color.
然而，它确实预示了男孩和女孩之间表现差异的某些系统性规律。当我们审视像警察枪击这样的事件时，我们总是试图在个体层面去理解它。如果发生了不好的事情，我们认为那一定是因为某人有不良意图。内隐偏见确实会作用于个体，但它最强烈的影响可能是在整个社区层面。这或许就是为什么一些针对非裔美国男性的警察枪击事件是由非裔美国警察执行的，以及为什么一些没有给有色人种开止痛药的医生本身可能就是有色人种。
Individuals can do their part to limit the effects of bias on their behavior, but if you want to fix the bias itself, well, that takes the whole village. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman, and Raina Cohen. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penben and Raina Cohen. It was edited by Tara Boyle. The music in today's show was composed by Ramthine Arableui. Our team includes Paath Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarrell, Kat Shukneck and Lu Sheikwaba. This week, our unsung hero is Caroline Dries, the senior director of field safety and security at NPR. In this time of coronavirus and nationwide protests, Caroline works tirelessly to make
个人可以尽自己的一份力量来限制偏见对其行为的影响，但如果你想消除偏见本身，嗯，那需要全村人的共同努力。本期《隐藏的大脑》由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼和雷娜·科恩制作。本期《隐藏的大脑》由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭本和雷娜·科恩制作。它由塔拉·博伊尔编辑。今天节目的音乐由拉姆蒂内·阿拉布卢伊创作。我们的团队包括帕思·沙ah、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔、卡特·舒克内克和卢·谢库瓦巴。本周，我们的无名英雄是NPR野外安全与安保高级总监卡罗琳·德里斯。在这个冠状病毒蔓延和全国抗议的时期，卡罗琳不知疲倦地工作，以确保
sure the people of NPR stay safe and healthy. Thank you Caroline for all that you do. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please do share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantan and this is NPR. You may have noticed something at all these protests over at police violence. There are a lot more white people there than you'd expect. But how long will that last? This, a wokening among white American voters, how far are they really willing to go beyond
NPR的人员安全和健康。感谢卡罗琳所做的一切。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦，这里是NPR。你可能在所有这些针对警察暴力的抗议活动中注意到了一件事。那里的白人比你预期的要多得多。但这能持续多久呢？白人美国选民中正在觉醒，他们真正愿意走多远，除了
dethroning Trump? Adam Surer on Race and Lessons from History. Listen and subscribe to It's Been a Minute from NPR. Trump. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拉下特朗普？亚当·萨勒谈种族与历史教训。请收听并订阅NPR的《It's Been a Minute》。特朗普。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。